good morning John crisis what kind of
crisis you want you want a
constitutional crisis got a couple of
those a week housing crisis sure
essential crisis always find the crisis
yeah scientists would like for you to
panic let's just go over to Google and
see if we could come up with a word and
see if there's a crisis about it oh
great Chiquita would like you to know
what they're doing about the banana
crisis so apparently we're having a
crisis crisis a crisis of crises and I'm
a proper middle-aged man so are you John
we should know how to deal with this so
here's like number one strategy
avoidance so start out gotta listen to
shaky shaky by daddy yankee you might
find solace and other activities YouTube
videos might be good for you poetry
poetry YouTube videos potato plants or a
friend or a dog what am I saying
I'm saying the first you gotta find your
shaky shake you got to connect with your
self as like a living sack of thinking
flesh which is amazing right it's
beautiful and majesty and like as far as
we know unique in the universe it's so
isolating to be in a crisis right to
think that everything's going terribly
and it's just and you have no path
forward and like yeah I recognize that
these are real problems but it's not
solving anything to be like just in a
terrified state of pan I and one of the
climate advocates who will say no and no
I don't I don't think that panic will
help but I think it would make sense to
panic panic is it is a normal emotion to
have in given the circumstances it's not
the most helpful why I think that having
all of these crises makes it harder to
connect because it seems like all those
things out there are more important than
all of these things in here all of
they're like taking care of yourself the
valuing yourself and the valuing of the
other people in your life am i reading a
book about this right now sure sure yes
so I'm thinking about it a lot and I'm
very tired because I'm Australia
hungover on too many V B's no I just
didn't sleep enough I think that paying
attention is important I think that
engaging with it is important I think
that there's a certain amount of
constant connection like looking for
dragging through trying to get the thing
as the moment that it comes out so that
I could just put two tweets in my mouth
like the peanut M&Ms and
I can't even chew there's so many in me
that's I want to engage with the crisis
but like or peanut M&Ms in your mouth at
the same time and I know this from
experience is not better than having two
seventeen is too many unhealthy it's
messy and it's not enjoyable here's my
middle-aged man take just because we're
not doing something perfect doesn't mean
that we're not doing taking climate as
an example here I know that the denial
is discouraging I know that there have
been a lot of deadlines crossed up to
this point we have started down a lot of
very promising interesting paths the
fact that America is like down below
nineteen ninety-five levels of carbon
dioxide is wild I wouldn't have been
able to tell you back then how we were
gonna do it it's like nobody knows now
how we're gonna get through our various
messes we've got ideas that we won't
know how we solved the problem until we
solve the problem it's deeply important
for me to feel like I can find a place
between panic and complacency I know
that place exists and here's how I find
it I imagine that the problem is this
huge mountain that we have to climb but
we can't see the ground we can't see the
path we can't see the time so all I can
do is take one step that feels like it's
in the right direction
and encourage my leaders to take steps
in those directions as well some except
the reason we can't do this stuff is cuz
we don't mean literally don't know how
we're gonna solve problems until we
solve them so we take the step and
things get better we get a little higher
up over the obstacle so my way is to
remember that all of the crises so far
were solved in ways we didn't understand
they would be solved we couldn't have
predicted that future we couldn't have
predicted this whew and so when I think
I don't know how to solve this problem
that's always how it is we never know
how to solve the problem we just thus
far just work a lot as individuals as a
collective and then we get there so far
John I'll see you on Tuesday
shake it baby Jackie Jackie Jackie
Johnny take